[Musica]
salve a tutti iniziò rompendo un po una
regola è come se fossimo in una delle
peggiori radio di provincia consentitemi
una piccola dedica al mio piccolino mio
figlio che c'è un anno e mezzo
antonio pio allora possiamo iniziare e
la parola educare e la parola ginger in
e dal punto di vista etimologico solo
l'una l'opposto dell'altro
infatti la parola educare deriva dal
latino ex ducere quindi tirare fuori
mentre la parola ingerire deriva da un
genere genere cioè portare dentro nel
agosto del 1974 25 persone provenienti
da 14 paesi nazioni diverse
si incontrarono a cuernavaca in messico
per scrivere quello che fu chiamato il
manifesto dei the scolarizzato ri era un
manifesto che criticava fortemente
l'istituzione scolastica così come la
intendiamo ancora oggi e proponeva
diciamo delle botteghe di uscire fuori
dalla scuola criticava il fatto che la
scuola l'istituzione scolastica fosse
figlia della rivoluzione industriale e
fosse organizzata come una linea di
fabbrica proponeva invece le botteghe
sociali cioè proponeva di uscire fuori
dalla scuola per imparare da un contesto
non per forza dalla bottega nel senso
che che noi possiamo intendere però da
un contesto che c'è fuori dalla scuola
anche la crisi
diciamola alle esigenze di
distanziamento dovute alla crisi
sanitaria hanno fatto riflettere molte
persone su questa opportunità cioè
sull'opportunità di cambiare la scuola
di farla uscire più fuori e quindi si
sono proposte le fattorie didattiche le
aziende agricole ma che le piazze i
monumenti come contesti educativi
facciamo un salto temporale e arriviamo
a parigi 10 novembre del 1989 a parigi
all'opéra comique di parigi viene
scritto e firmato il manifesto dello
slow food è un manifesto che viene
scritto tra l'altro da personalità del
calibro di dario fo francesco guccini
sergio staino e naturalmente carlo
petrini in questo manifesto si legge una
critica forte del fast food
dell'omologazione del cibo che viene
proposto un nuovo paradigma paradigma
basato su consapevolezza e sostenibilità
sostenibilità a questo paradigma viene
dato proprio il nome di slow food che
cosa c'entrano a che cosa hanno in
comune questi due manifesti
apparentemente nulla ma vedremo in
seguito
io sono nato nel 1975 e quindi un anno
dopo l'incontro di carne vata e quando
carlo petrini si incontrava e scriveva
il manifesto dello slow food in qualche
modo io avevo solamente 14 anni però
questi due manifesti hanno condizionato
la mia gitano definito la mia identità
perché oggi sono un attivista del
movimento
e mi occupo di educazione in quell
accensione che dicevano proprio
polarizzatori perché mi occupo di
fattorie didattiche però non sarei del
tutto onesto con voi se dicessi che sono
proprio quei due momenti storici che
hanno influenzato la la mia vita perché
in realtà essendo un campano come
immagino conti di lui
diciamo che i campani avevano già visto
prima quello che hanno scritto poi le
scolarizzato ricche e slow food nel nel
loro manifesto però di questo ne
parleremo a brevissimo vediamo che cosa
aveva indotto quelle persone quei due
gruppi diversi di persone a incontrarsi
e a riflettere insieme e scrivere dei
documenti che avessero una portata
globale cioè che valessero in tutto il
mondo per fare questo dobbiamo leggere
qualcosina che viene tratta proprio dal
dal loro manifesto allora nel manifesto
di slow food troviamo scritto questo
nostro secolo
nato e cresciuto sotto il segno della
civiltà industriale ha prima inventato
la macchina e poi ne ha fatto il proprio
modello di vita
la velocità è diventata la nostra catena
tutti noi siamo in preda allo stesso
virus
la fast life che coinvolge le nostre
abitudini ci assale fin delle nostre
case ci si rinchiude a nutrirci nei fast
food mentre nel manifesto di
dei des polarizzatori di cuernavaca
troviamo scritto questo queste funzioni
di socializzazione costituiscono il
curriculum nascosto della
scolarizzazione gli effetti di queste
funzioni stanno precipitando nella
nostra società eni realizzata la scuola
espone sono sempre più messe in dubbio
sia dai minori che dagli adulti
gli studenti si impongono
progressivamente più ribelli ed apatici
impiegati si lamentano che le scuole o
gli facilitano forza di lavoro
efficiente ed obbediente padri figli
cominciano a dubitare che la scuola
realmente affronta fornisce opportunità
uguali che siano un mezzo sicuro per
fare fortuna che per avere successo
ci sono alcune parole che si rincorrono
in questi due manifesti no c'è
sicuramente una critica del modello
dell'industrializzazione prima e della
modello capitalistico dopo e la proposta
in realtà è comune c'è la proposta
riguarda uscire fuori la andare fuori
sede scolarizzato redice conosciamo
fuori dalla scuola e quelli di profondo
e dicevano usciamo fuori dai fast food e
dai centri commerciali quindi in questo
momento tra l'altro in cui noi tutti ci
stiamo riappropriando del fuori questo
può avere una una grande valenza ed è
per questo che soprattutto nel mondo
della scuola si sta si sta facendo
questa riflessione
ma vediamo un pochino più attentamente
che cosa vuol dire uscire fuori per slow
food uscire fuori vuol dire
intanto interrogarsi sul percorso che fa
il cibo cioè cercare di andare incontro
a chi produce il proprio cibo
noi tutti andando a fare la spesa al
supermercato
spesso non ci non ci chiediamo più qual
è il percorso che fa che fa il nostro
cibo e potrei fare l'esempio di tanti
marchi ad esempio di olio extravergine
d'oliva per noi consideriamo italiani ma
che non sono più i tanti italiani da da
tanto tempo ma questo per farvi un
esempio slow food propone di andare
incontro ai piccoli produttori
all'agricoltura familiare di piccola
scala
proprio per anche per quegli effetti
positivi sull'ambiente
quindi di tutela dal punto di vista
degli ecosistemi della tenuta degli
ecosistemi che l'agricoltura di piccola
scala e familiare svolge in tutto il
mondo e che di cui sentivamo anche nel
nell'intervento nell'intervento
precedente quindi andare incontro dove
nei mercati contadini nei punti di
vendita diretta
anche qui anche nel nel momento peggiore
del lock down le aziende agricole non si
sono fermate e il momento di relazione
di vendita diretta è diventato è
cresciuto questo questa parte questa
modalità di distribuzione e di acquisito
e di acquisto del cibo quindi andare
fuori uscire e andare incontro al cibo
per imparare cercare di non farsi
mangiare dal cibo non farsi ingerire
cioè non ridurre il cibo a una
commodities a una merce a restituirgli
valore e restituiti valore che
innanzitutto restituendo un valore alle
persone che lo producono corn appunto
seguendo quel paradigma di sostenibilità
e di consapevolezza
vediamo invece che cosa intendevano per
uscire fuori in sé scolarizzato ri
intanto la critica
l'abbiamo l'abbiamo l'abbiamo vista
prima era soprattutto al al modo di
formare e individui che era basato più
sul sulle esigenze della produttività no
anche il fatto di rinchiuderli diciamo
in back produttivi cioè come se fosse
una vera una vera linea di produzione
che solo le classi la prima la seconda
la terza la quarta il fatto di dare
delle delle valutazioni senza però
dall'altra parte e provare come dicevano
non poco tempo fa ma già agli inizi del
secolo scorso pedagogisti del calibro di
maria montessori cercare di andare
incontro alle allenta allen alle
tendenze agli stimoli e alla curiosità
del bambino prima e dell'individuo
poi però dicevamo prima che noi campani
ciò abbiamo visto un po prima tutte
queste cose e allora vorrei dimostrato e
lo so quanti di voi si ricordano l'anno
in cui fu firmato il manifesto di parigi
1989 vediamo invece quanti di lui si
ricordano di che anno era questo film
[Musica]
le bottiglie devi asciugare bene ma lo
vuoi capire che se ci fanno acqua dentro
ci siamo anticipati un po vicina
mi spiace per le bottiglie le devi
asciugare bene ma lo vuoi capire che se
ci fanno acqua dentro la parola permette
la bottiglia si chiama signorina su
quale forma gioca più in quanto contino
stamattina
causa vincere per fare le borse di
pomodori in casa ci vuole pazienza per
chi non viene pazienza del bottino le
boe fa tu guarda io le immagini la carta
di giornale che licata mente e poi leggo
che hanno pianto dentro all'acqua fredda
e misto accorto che non si tutto nel
lungo all'altro per esempio io sono
convinto che la carta di settimanali non
è buona
no no no perché sottile al tonight osta
la signora carratù per l'abbonamento con
grazia quando facile bottini di pomodoro
e anche un poco grazie un poco il
mattino ebbe poi non ci crederete ma con
grazie alle bottiglie si scavano con il
mattino non tanto genoa questo passaggio
[Musica]
io non capisco perché in questa casa non
dovete comprare il comodo riscatto la
come fanno tutte le missioni che sono
pomodori che non abbiamo conosciuto di
persona piuttosto perché non me la farò
una maratona papa beato te che mantini
niente da fare
e tu ritieni da fare è poi così
finiscono le compensazioni nomi con un
interrogativo inevaso 1984 quindi
abbiamo anticipato il manifesto dello
slow food di cinque anni ma non solo non
abbiamo solamente anticipato perché
anche il tema del concedersi giusto
tempo per la scelta degli alimenti e per
la preparazione degli alimenti professor
bellavista dice alla figlia maggiore ma
tutto ti rafa è la domanda che dovremmo
farci un po tutti quanti roma ma tu che
tira fanno il momento in cui stai lì per
acquistare o per preparare il tuo cibo
prova a utilizzare quel momento quel
tempo per fare qualche domanda a qualche
domanda è più è però gli avevo fatto vi
avevo promesso che per entrambi i
manifesti ne siamo stati lungimiranti
allora vediamo che cosa ci dice la
pedagogista americana c'era il cirs
rispetto alla relazione tra bambini e
natura e dice è stato chiaramente
dimostrato che quando i bambini fanno
esperienza diretta di gioco e
apprendimento in contesti di natura
questo contribuisce positivamente al
loro sviluppo cognitivo fisico sociale
ed emotivo quando la natura fa parte
della loro vita quotidiana i bambini
tendono ad essere più felici più sani
più intelligenti più collaborativi e più
premurosi
io non so se voi avete mai sentito
parlare del fenomeno del fenomeno degli
hikikomori è un fenomeno abbastanza
recente la parola e giapponese
ma i primi articoli sono del 2008 solo
che rifiutano di uscire per paura della
relazione con il mondo esterno
e allora lo avevo anticipato prima però
lui il più grande di tutti
massimo già aveva visto in anticipo
questa tendenza a benzina meno per kakà
necessari scivoli mite nessuna nessuna
diplomata e cosa pensa di riuscirci devi
salvare loeb è che chi sta meglio
sintesi su musiche da me presi da un
esule riuscito da patenti sui temi fiat
i bambini a strati poche febbre ma
rubata che non può di un bar a bambine e
bambini bambine che vanno male i gomiti
fi unendo ma ricovero per intuisce ma
non appena decisivo al complesso per
attesa forse di quanto premier honor che
scenderà in gara europei come i famosi
si rinasce umana bambini che io faccio
perché a meno per monti mai umani uomini
farlo massima animata a teatro a 0 ma
ben ali
due bambini
[Applauso]
come come vedete sapevamo ci avevamo noi
campani ci avevamo ci avevamo visto
lungo però per entrambe il paradigma
nell uscire fuori allora voglio chiudere
con con un augurio quale augurio
migliore farci che non ritrovarci fuori
e non fuori più eco che meno eco in un
fuori che ci dia gli strumenti per non
essere portati dentro non essere
ingeriti dalle logiche del marketing e
per cercare invece di tirare fuori il
meglio che in ognuno di noi
questo è l'augurio che faccio a tutti
quanti noi oggi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]